you have no idea what you have unleashed
[Applause]
how did you get out of that plane
there's not a single scratch on your
body you are alive because Ilhwa cursed
cursed but what the ultimate evil
welcome to a new world
of gods and monsters
you saw that right she did something to
me
the very essence of evil cause to know
it takes a monster
defeat a monster
that's right that's right
mr. Martin you have no idea what you
have unleashed
she's unlike anything we've ever faced
welcome to prodigy
my character Nick he's just caught up in
this whole world that he doesn't want to
get caught up in whoo
I'm a doctor my name is Jekyll dr. Henry
Jekyll
the central character behind all the
events of the movie is dr. Henry Jekyll
famous for being Jekyll and Hyde dr.
Jekyll operates a thing called perdition
and pretty Geum essentially is an
organization that in points evil and
tries to neutralize it
we recognize examine contain destroy
evil they study the mythologies and
monsters the histories of them princess
ha Manette she's selected you as the
vessel for the ultimate evil it's a
science for them and what I liked about
that idea was if we're gonna ground the
monsters in a reality then let's ground
it in science
we like the idea that pretty Geum was
hiding in plain sight in the Natural
History Museum and that Jekyll could use
the resources of the museum to further
his own research into monsters there's a
lot to find out with Jay : it's not
giving too much away to say that he has
quite a clear understanding of evil it
takes a monster to defeat a monster
I love the element of mystery it's quite
dangerous and exciting
there's learn to be wary of an airline
machine
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
you
you